después de que el agricultor de manzanas
y la cadena de país se involucran en
este contrato a término
howard como lo vimos en el vídeo
anterior algunas preguntas comenzaron a
aparecer en sus mentes y la pregunta
principal fue cuál es la otra persona
que quizás no sea capaz de mantener el
contrato y que a esto le vamos a llamar
riesgo de contraparte algo que
esencialmente me refiero cuando hablo de
la contraparte es que la contraparte del
agricultor es latina de los países y la
contraparte de la cadena será el
agricultor y hay un riesgo de que la
otra parte cuál sea de estas dos sea
incapaz de resguardar el contrato la
segunda cuestión que comienza a
preocuparle es este qué tal si alguno de
ellos o ambos llegan a tener
pensamientos segundo sobre el contrato
que vayan más allá de este contrato a
terminal que fueron capaces que una vez
dentro del contrato tal vez vender la
obligación a alguien más y negociar la
avv la manera de negociar dicho contrato
y bien como otra cuestión sería que si
tú llegas a comercializar el contrato
como podríamos nosotros saber qué lado
aparte o la contraparte también llega a
negociarla o a comercializarla y esto
podría hacer con un millón de libras y
si son 200 mil dólares que quizás ellos
querrían hacerlos para enfrentar algún
tipo de situación cuantitativamente
menor y si de repente se le prende el
foco y dice vamos a estandarizar estos
contratos a término qué pasaría si sólo
creamos varios de estos contratos cuando
alguien realmente quiera entrar en uno
de estos para estandarizar los entonces
escribiendo por aquí vamos a escribir
que son mil libras de manzanas miles de
manzanas para entregar en noviembre 15
15 de noviembre donde cada uno de estos
contratos dirá lo mismo dirá que son mil
libras de manzanas con la misma fecha de
entrega la del 15 de noviembre y
supongamos que este hombre también es el
hombre más rico de su ciudad que ha
estado participando en una bolsa de
valores y ahora que estandariza los
contratos estará vendiendo la ayuda a la
contraparte al igual que estarles
brindando garantía que será garantía
para cada uno de estos contratos que
prácticamente está habla
de todas las contrapartes de riesgo para
brindar a la gente una mayor confianza
en la negociación por lo que
repentinamente pasa es que ahora cada
uno de estos chicos que tenían sus
contratos no tendría que hacer un único
contrato no tendrán que hacer cada uno
de estos fowards ellos estarán
estandarizados con los seis de estos y
no habrá nueva negociación bueno qué
pasaría si estos pequeños agricultores
el agricultor y el agricultor b
quisieran realizar transacciones con el
cliente en un cierto paréntesis de
tiempo y que estuviera por aquí el
cliente se y el cliente de donde ellos
acordarán no arreglarán un precio donde
hagan que el pequeño agricultor
incremente más sus ganancias y donde si
cualquiera de ellos quiere salirse del
contrato porque en el mercado han
encontrado un mejor precio quieren
tratar con otra persona este contrato a
término esencialmente termina siendo lo
mismo pero estandarizado que nos puede
dar una fracción de dinero en una cierta
fecha específica que bien es algunas
contraparte que viene del hecho de
negociar las mil
de manzanas y estos contratos tipo
forward pero estandarizados son los
famosos llamados futuros son los futuros
son estandarizados y negociados en un
mercado con regulación